hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie Guide and now that the oscar
nominations have been released I thought
that what I would do is every week in
the lead-up to Oscars I'll take a look
at a different category and also give
you my predictions so we're gonna start
this week with the Best Documentary
category and the best foreign language
film category let's start with the docs
and the nominees are abacus
small enough to jail faces places Ikaros
strong island and last men in aleppo now
starting with Icarus this is a
fascinating documentary
it follows brian Fogle as he looks into
the issue of doping by doping himself to
see if he can make his cycling better
and what he ends up doing is uncovering
a huge Russians doping scandal were you
the mastermind that cheated the Olympics
yes abacus takes a look at a tiny US
family-run Bank which was the only bank
to face charges after the financial
disaster of 2008 frankly if every bank
had underwritten as well as abacus we
would have had a financial crisis
faces places is my personal favorite of
the bunch it's made by street artist
junior and legendary French filmmaker
Agnes Varda these two travel around in a
photobooth van they take big pictures of
people piece them up on walls
larger-than-life
it is sweet it is charming and this
makes Agnes Varda the oldest Oscar
nominee in Oscar history at 89 years old
she's just one year younger than the
awards themselves the beauty see the
perverted emotion issue
strong Island is a very heartbreaking
documentary about the murder of a young
man and how the system let his killer go
free
made by Yantz Ford this kid is going to
actually get away with murder and last
man in Aleppo goes into the Syrian civil
war following the white helmets which is
the volunteer aid group as you can
imagine it is deeply powerful sad and
also inspirational when you see these
heroes who go into dangerous situations
to help out so my prediction for the
winner I think it's either last men in
Aleppo or faces places I'm gonna go out
in the limb and say that faces places
we'll take the documentary prize let's
go on to the Foreign Film category
there's so many great choices here the
nominees are a fantastic woman from
Chile Lovelace from Russia on body and
soul from Hungary the square from Sweden
and the insult from Lebanon so taking a
closer look this is the very first time
a movie from Lebanon has ever been
nominated for an Oscar and it is not
without controversy there's been a lot
of boycotts against the film this is
about an incident between a Lebanese
Christian and a Palestinian refugee when
he commits a disability
[Music]
enter xiulet loveless meanwhile is a
gripping drama thriller about a young
boy who goes missing and these strange
parents who were trying to find him
beautifully shot engaging throughout on
body and soul was a surprise inclusion I
thought in the fade or Foxtrot from
Israel would get in this category but
this movie is really interesting it's
about to slaughterhouse workers who
discover that they share the same dream
where they fall in love so they decide
to try and make it come true there's a
GUI would keep them but I'm gonna stay
I'm gonna do so one window and close the
sqaure won the top prize at the Cannes
Film Festival you can also see it this
weekend on Fandango now it's a great
watch at home I highly recommend it a
satirical look at modern art privilege
the class system
it'll make you squirm it'll make you
laugh and this is the 16th film from
Sweden to have been nominated in the
Best Foreign Language Film category if
it wins it'll be the fourth time Sweden
has taken this award it's also got my
strictly
and you can see a fantastic woman in
more theaters from this weekend this
features a brilliant performance by
Daniela Vega who is a trans woman and
she plays a trans woman who is
struggling with the family of her dead
boyfriend she wants to get equal rights
and she is mistreated by everyone to
petition diversity or no
[Music]
so my prediction I think it'll either go
to a fantastic woman or the square I'm
gonna give the edge to the square after
it's been picking up a lot of awards
this season but also in theaters this
week you can see a little indie horror
thriller called like me this is a funny
and disturbing take on social media it's
about a loner who starts to go on a
crime spree to get more likes and more
views after a video of her being
extremely violent goes viral it's
directed by Robert McLaren has a lot to
say about isolation in this very
connected world and has a great
performance by Addison
Timlin who you might remember from
little sister are you scared of me and
at home on Fandango now as well as the
square I definitely recommend you watch
the Florida Project this is a film which
should have been nominated for Academy
Awards but it did pick up one for Best
Supporting Actor for Willem Dafoe it's
directed by Sean Baker who specializes
in looking at marginalized communities
that we don't normally see on the big
screen this time it's all about be
hidden homeless who are living on the
outskirts of Disney wealth these
so-called happiest place on earth
she's back to cries making eyes telling
the girls were about to cry it's got
very naturalistic acting a lot to say
and an ending that had me in tears see
the Florida project on Fandango now
another one to watch at home is
Professor Marsden and the wonder women
I'm really surprised that this film went
under the radar it's directed by Angela
Robinson and it tells the true story of
how Wonder Woman the comics came to be
professor Marston was the guy who was
behind the comics and he designed them
to be very feminist he also was in a
polyamorous relationship with his wife
and a young student maybe I just want
her because
you think it's possible to love two
people at the same time the movie deals
with very taboo subjects like threesomes
and bondage in a very elegant way it's
got the soft touch of a woman and I
recommend it if nothing else to see
Rebecca Hall once again give a fantastic
performance
professor Marston and the wonder women
is on Fandango now so there you have it
my first Oscar predictions plus a couple
of options to watch in theaters and at
home and I want to know from you which
films do you think will win in the Best
Documentary and Best Foreign Language
Film categories let me know in the
comments below or on Twitter at Alicia
Malone and I'll see you soon
[Music]